[Music]
angelina is doubling down in her divorce
battle with brad pitt
et obtained new court documents where
angie's lawyers are firing back at brad
basically telling him to butt out of her
request to remove the private judge
in their nearly four-year divorce
angelina wants a new judge
claiming the current one is biased
because he worked with brad's lawyers on
other cases brad says that's not the
case accusing angie of trying to stall
ahead of their child custody case in
october in a new statement to et
angelina's attorney says
angie just wants quote a fair trial
based on facts with no special favors
extended to
either side meanwhile we're getting a
look at new behind-the-scenes video of
angelina in her disney plus movie
the one and only ivan streaming tomorrow
you're funny
ruby sweetie try and get some sleep
that's angelina as the voice of a circus
elephant she fell in love with the story
thanks to one of her kids well shiloh
years ago
told me that she'd read a book that she
loved and she wanted me to read it
and yeah angelina got into character
rocking an elephant onesie during her
recording sessions with 10 year old
co-star
brooklyn prince i said hey
why don't we wear elephant onesies and
she was like
sure how could you say no to that